Now they they credit you with giving Taylor
Swift the idea to rerecord her albums.
You're getting a little cut of that, you
know what I mean? No.
And it's like, here's the thing.
Like, she would have come up with the idea.
I just happened to tweet her. Then somebody
asked me an interview like, oh, did she
respond? I was like, oh, she sent me flowers
once. That was so cool. And then it turned
into she sends me flowers for everything.
And I was like, she's not a florist.
She didn't. She just sent it the one time,
like, I was like, what? But yeah, no, I
didn't. I don't think I gave her any idea.
She wouldn't have thought of on her own.
So. I think you did.
I think you did. Yeah, I think you did.
I think you may have done it. Yeah.
I'm not here to start nothing.
I just want, like, point 1%.
Yeah.
We're not here to stir up any trouble.
That's not our jobs.
But we definitely just want to tell you how
we feel. And I think it's safe to say that
we.
Also flowers is not an acceptable form of
payment. Yeah. So yeah, I would suggest, you
know, you talk to her like real.
Don't send me no f***ing.
Rose. You know what I mean?
Give me the check.
Yeah, I need the check.
Yeah, I want to get that.
We got children out here.
Yeah, we're on it for you.
Thank you, thank you.
Kelly, what was your favorite album of the
year?
Oh, man.
Teddy swims lose control.
That was a good one. Oh, Teddy.
Swim.
Uh, bell bottom country.
Lainey Wilson. I like that one.
Lainey Wilson I know, I know, both of them.
Those are two great choices.
I'm with you on your choices.
I might be going against the grain, but I'm
gonna say Andre 3000 flutes.
Yeah.
What do you mean, going against the grain?
I'm with you, man.
Thank you. Huh? Thank you.
Did you hear that album, Kelly?
I just was talking about Andre 3000 coming
out with something that's so cool. Yes, it's
a flute.
It's a flute out. It's been a minute.
And he came back with flutes.
Yeah. So what do you mean, it's flutes?
What we mean is playing the flute.
He left for 17 years and then decided to
come back playing only flutes.
Flutes? Yeah, for the entire 90 minute
album. Yeah, but like, what we have to deal
with now.
But it's like cool flute.
It's not like regular flute.
It's like cool flute.
Yeah. Like, if you if you in the flute music,
you're you're.
You know what I mean.
No drums.
No. Just just just flutes.
Different ones.
It's just.
And we just have to take it.
Yeah. Do you have a favorite moment from
your show this year and your least favorite?
This one? I like that question.
Yeah. Thank you. Good question.
My favorite moment was guys were talking
about they were on tour and they were
talking about the tour bus. And I was like,
oh yeah, I love the tour bus. And this one
kid. And I say kid because I'm 41 and
they're not. And it was like, were you like
touring, doing improv?
Oh no.
And I was like, oh.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't know, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know who you are. I go and.
I was like, nope, nope.
Uh, well, I was singing, but um, but no.
Yeah. And I just kind of made a joke, but
that was my favorite moment.
Just to humble. You got to punch him in the
face, Kelly. That's what you go.
That's right. That's what I would do.
Dude.
Just be different, right?
Be your own person. That's why you've
achieved so much.
That's the difference. That's the difference
between me and Kelly Clarkson right there.
All right Kelly, last question.
What are you looking forward to in 2024?
I'm looking forward to saying no.
Interesting I'm looking like I don't say no
enough I say yes a lot.
Well hold on now.
Let me ask you a couple questions.
Are you gonna say yes to everything?
What are you doing?
I'm saying yes to a lot of things.
I'm. I'm still. I'm still at about 99%.
We're gonna keep the yeses coming.
I'm up there. Yeah, as much as we possibly
can. Yup. Uh, don't need your nose right
now. Kelly. You know what?
I want to thank you.
Not just for being a guest, but just for
being a dope person with dope energy.
Every time I see you, it's nothing but great
vibes. And today was nothing different.
Guys. Thank Kelly one time man.
Thank you. Kelly. Please, please.
Be sure
to catch my improv tour.
All right. Yeah.
You better punch him in the face next time
you see him. That's what you need to do.